here is a new episode of evidence of
tour if nation I am Alberto
last time we saw comments
pay an application remotely
runs on an android device is like
see what the listener events are
linked to an html element
in this episode we will see two instead
other panels of chromebook tools that
are the network panel respectively
in which we can see the requests
http that are carried out and the
timeline panel in which in particular
this episode we will see how to analyze the
declines in the performance of
rendering of a web page
ok let's see here
the next request from the boss tells us
hi alberto the problem oct not
it works what's wrong then
bring up the pop up about
click on the respective option in the
menu and this is what it says
this is a game in which the anci lady
shuriken error for in the number of
visits
so let's try to understand what that
cause this error to do this
take the magnifying glass here and
we select about from the menu so it
we highlighted in the panel of
elements and from here we can go to
see if listener we have the listener
for the click action with the mouse and here
the respective code is the function that
it is executed which is this melted
the cup in turn this function which
love the to coast to function with these
parameters
let's quickly see what
are and what the parameters do are a
data url them post is a call back la
function executes a call le jobs a
this scream with these parameters and
when it is done it will be called
this callback with data and response
we will have received you
then returning to ceva pop up
the callback function that comes
performed is this part summer stars
menshov earth for example these
operations take input data and go
to check that the first character is
a symbol of minor if it is not
launch error otherwise xml e
then show a law now we can
analyze the data we received
incoming in two ways one by issuing a
breakpoint here and going to see that
object type is this an alternative
and use the network panel in fact
if we go here
we see that there is this request that is
was done when we clicked
on the about option we can
see again when i am here
here is the request again
with the network panel here it will be
we select we can see that we have
all information on eders of
request and response is a preview
of the response we received in
this case we can see that
instead we receive an SM as an answer
these data here where it tells us that
these pious has been deprecated that
we must instead the jason ok maybe
we could have known more about it
nice but at least we found out what it is
the problem
so let's lose it by luck
I had already prepared the function that
all a jason passes and then we go to
call this instead of in operation
that can also xml lady at the exchange
we call jazz I like xml we talk
back to the page
click on the bout button and that's it
now the number of visits has appeared
of this page
we can go see the panel
network and then we see that we have the
request we made
we can see here it is if there
we click we can see the same
what for those to ask here and paolo
why give an answer with our e
jason
in the last episode
had asked to modify the
behaviors of this button and of
make sure that when cyclical they go
above then they are loaded into the belt
little dogs instead of a solo
however obviously problems are not finished
here we say hello alberto the shurikens
they are slow do not kill take them fast
ok
let's try a little we put 200c together
at the belt and we launch them
actually there are some words to say
back lenses we can see that
chrome is not fast enough to
efficiently redesign everyone
these elements to try to understand
what's the problem
we use the fein e screen
here we can see all the events that
they fall during the execution of the page
frame after frame maybe now update the
page many colored bars appear
of different length
whose color can be explained here
Blue walls are logging events
collegiate of writings violet rendering e
green paintings also here we have some
vertical bars that are
respectively the don
contemplates an amendment of them in the
our case, however, we are interested in this
part here with the suter in then
let's add flowers we make
start a recording and leave them
here we can see that the graph is
populates with many colored bars
we come to the registration and we go to
see what it is here we have one
horizontal line representing the
30 frames per second
here we have so many vertical walls that
represent law of execution of
every single frame those that go
over the first 30 second line
it means that they are failing and therefore
we can't get to 3 from the first to the
second but it will certainly be less
we can click here to select
this area we can make it here
below in the diagram drawn where we see
there are several purple horizontal lines
which are much larger than all the
other
here we also see the code that comes
followed in this case is of type
calculation of the style we laugh at above
this function brings us the function
anime it being called in
continuation through a set time out
the operation that is performed that
cause the problem is this here where to
move on you and then to animate it
system change it
the property letter pro vita css
which is very inefficient because it doesn't
we are exploiting class acceleration
we can try to solve using
instead the css 3 transformer e properties
francisco
little parenthesis always better
use a class there is sexy instead
that we're going to type it through games in
this case is only a
let us therefore take the example
this new code
we comment on this and this is no longer there
need animation because there
will think css 3 properties except yes
start the page made in the screen
timeline bit to gate this fact that
no need 200 usual load we do
starting a recording and
then let's see that they are already a lot
slower and here we can see that
all the bars now are always a
a bit long because there is work anyway
to do to draw but they are almost
all except these initials under the
30 first second line so so
we managed to improve a little
rendering performance of ours
application thanks for your attention
in the next episode we will talk about
we will talk about fine memory problems